saying I should be both you may not have
any I don't think you should be but I
don't see there's no distance between AD
Miliband and David loves I see there's
not a big enough difference between ed
miliband exactly the family back home
Charlotte Charlotte's question was
lately about the next generation here we
have a experts saying that if we
continue with austerity cuts by 2020
that are going to be 1 million more
children across the UK living in poverty
that would be a betrayal of the next
generation while I am proposing is
responsible modest spending increases it
still gets the deficit down because yes
that is important but doesn't do it by
he paying more and more pain onto the
backs of the people who can least afford
it and I want to say to add we share a
desire to see the back of the Tories but
surely we don't want to replace the
Tories with Tory light so that's not to
replace the torrent is something thanks